two outs nobody on for christian yelich
the former national league mvp oh
great that was
are you kidding me
wow
his reaction when they ran when he ran
by him because you know what great
players respect great players they do
and they respect this play too because
it's slicing away from trevor that's
what makes it hard but then even
trevor's got to kind of put the glove
over his mouth and just kind of laughs
and right now he's probably like sorry
dude
as brendan rogers will step to the plate
and there's second base tonight
here with the rockies go after the first
pitch and in the right field garcia runs
it down
nice play out there by avi garcia
in right center field to take away extra
bases first out of the unit that is a
big outfit look at the size
angles out perfectly and able to make
the catch fully stretched out and able
to stay on his feet heck of a play by
garcia and he gets the out and he keeps
throwing it first so it remains so one
and two on rymel two outs in the second
no score
one shot
stops sensor beats the throw runner
makes it one nothing
great play by adamus
and great job by senzitella to make sure
he got to second and the force wasn't
available it's a 15-game hitting streak
one-nothing colorado and again taking
the ball the other way if it wasn't for
the athletic play by adamus just to get
this ball i mean he stretches out we've
seen the shortstops make some wonderful
plays already in this ball game the
difference was just couldn't get
anything on that throw but antonio had
already beat the throw to second base
ace is loaded two men out for charlie
blackmon
and he hits the first pitch one with the
stop and the throws in time oh what a
play
by colton wong oh making it happen off
the injured list tonight and taking away
at least a run and likely two
that's what a gold glover looks like
ladies and gentlemen
plays a game we saw six errors last
night originally seven but a scoring
decision knocked at the six as louisia
turns on one deep to left that's gone
and we are tied in the third he's driven
in all the runs so far for the brewers
in this series a big fly finally for the
brewers it's been a while since the
brewers have been a home run you can see
that pitch middle in took a little bit
off of it and aureus gave it a pretty
good ride to left here's jackie bradley
jr
and jbj with a drive in the right center
field and that's it again
brewers will grab the lead adamus is in
peel it around third and
he will score a two-run double from
jackie bradley jr to give the brewers
the lead jbj needed that in the worst
way he's been scuffling up there to play
a ringing double into the gap all the
way to the wall clearing the bases still
nobody out and jackie bradley jr in with
a double here's vogelback
we'll go back with a grandpa off of
mcmahon that'll get jackie bradley jr
home
and it's a three three-run fifth for the
bruise that was a good jinx by the way
you just said we've seen some pretty
good defense well done yeah check this
out about as routine as it gets he can't
believe he missed it mcmahon looking in
his glove saying where is it not sure
where it hit him hit him in the hint in
the glove yeah
did he miss the glove hit him in the
knee i think and you do have to score
minimum one here you're open more than
that but you have to take some of the
momentum back away from the brewers
and this ball is locked to deep left
yelidge makes a running catch
here comes tapia home
four to two he'll put a charge in one
now to right right center
this ball charged at the left field line
makes it a one run game as he cruises to
second with a pinch hit double and now
dawson gets a curve ball no excuse me
that was a fastball i just thought the
way he went down to get it he turned on
that 96 miles an hour
he's been something else
swing pitch goes in favor of the hitter
to hampson so it's two and one
evening at 20 at the blake
ripped it right past hurry us the third
i mean he made the dive for it brendan
enjoying the best month of his young
career
one for three and he was robbed back in
the second inning 1-0 this ball is to
right this one is federer mcmahon
picking up stu cole carl will send them
mcmahon is
going to score standing up 5-4 colorado
coming through again brendan rodgers
a little two-out magic too
you know double two left field now how
about a double to right field
knows that hey i'm gonna have to go
because garcia
in right got this ball back into colton
wall so matt's cutting the bases
perfectly catch that inside corner
and then not even a throw
14th rbi for
giving his brendan's
some moments in his brief time as a
brewer another opportunity now in the
ninth inning
and abdominals with a shot down the left
hand line of base hit narvaez rounding
third he will score
back-to-back doubles and we're tied in
colorado well brewer's not messing
around attacking early
arrives on the second pitch and dom is
jumping on the first pitch
and ripping it and there's your go ahead
run now at second base after adamus
drives in noria's
one and two on the pitch hitter derrick
fisher
pays
baud gave up the equalizer but boy did
he pull his net
and prevent the go-ahead run so we'll go
extra innings and here's the situation
milwaukee six and four and extra innings
this year the rockies are three
and three
center field sinking liner
the catch was made
what a grab by hanson
it's all about the jump
and then you have to have no fear
because if you dive and this skips by
you oh boy
hung up long enough
true spring catch cole long didn't he
didn't know what to do out at second
base he's like god do i get out
by that time it's too late what a play
by g hamp at center field how many good
defensive plays have we seen
all right half a dozen tonight cool as i
get wait what do i do i don't know i
have any shot on a base hitter getting
mcmahon here's the 2-2
base hit mcmahon around the third he's
coming home
and he'll score the rockies win it again
lucky number seven
first walk-offs this year for the
rockies
needs all the baseball
some more lodo magic
baseball's fun at 20th and blake
and after all the change-ups he just
punches this ball on the fastball to
right field
garcia had to run a long way for it
max known i'm going to score throw way
off line and by that time everybody was
out at first base yeah come on give me a
big hug let's go